in a remarkable sign of unity
three-quarters of un members voted to
condemn russia's war with ukraine
even moscow's allies china and iran
chose to abstain rather than support
putin they have come to deprive ukraine
of the very right to exist it came after
an emotional plea from ukraine's
ambassador
and firm warnings from the u.s that
civilians could soon face exceptionally
lethal russian weapons now it appears
russia is preparing to increase the
brutality of its campaign against
ukraine russia dismissed it all as a
western pressure campaign one that is
squeezing moscow at every level
airplane makers boeing and airbus are
the latest western corporations to cut
off supplies to russian companies while
the u.s announced deeper sanctions
nothing is off the table the white house
has fully blocked russia's defense
sector and take an aim at putin's allies
in belarus
during his state of the union address
tuesday president biden announced plans
to target russia's elite oligarchs
directly we're joining with european
allies to find and seize their yachts
their luxury apartments their private
jets
russia is now so deeply isolated the u.s
secretary of state assured everyday
russians that they are not the target
the economic costs that we've been
forced to impose on russia are not aimed
at you
they're aimed at compelling your
government to stop its actions to stop
its aggression so far none of it has
convinced putin to blink
yet nato allies remain steadfast that
there's only so far they're willing to
go the u.s insists it has no plans to
get directly involved in the conflict
and it's rejecting that repeated request
from ukraine to establish a no-fly zone
one that would stop russian airstrikes
jackson prosko global news washington